there are things that are triggers for
me now like three words scary difficult
hard if I say those think those I have
to go do that thing if you said hey Evan
you should go do X and I said that's
really hard now I got to do it cuz I
don't want to accept hard as a reason to
not do so the Doritos bag is one of the
more challenging things to to connect
with cuz that's more of a hard push
where when you're on a diet the usual
strategy is get rid of the food and I
think that's a good first step so scary
difficult heart is one the other is I
have a boom boom boom test which is if
my heart is beaten out of my chest
that's a physical manifestation of scary
difficult hard I used to want people to
cancel on me like if I saw you I'd say
yes in 2 months we'll do this thing but
then I'd see like oh my God Patty and
today I hope she cancels I don't want to
disappoint her this is going to be
terrible even if I showed up and vomited
all over my microphone and the camera
because I was so nervous I would still
mentally reward myself to say you did
the hard thing need motivation watch
your top 10 with believe Nation head S
car Michael and I make these videos
because I need them for me because I
want to wake up every day and watch a
video that puts me in a mindset to
believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well okay so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan carmichel and I take on his top 10
rules for Success
enjoy rule number two enjoy the process
you have to do the work that you don't
see as work
uh Jerry Seinfeld calls it the torture
that you can endure it's like for a lot
of people what you're doing St up to
three in the morning just to do a
YouTube Interview people are like dude
that's crazy that's torture I would
never do that right for people jumping
into my schedule like to make three
YouTube videos every day they would
think that that's tortured for me it's
fun I enjoy the process if you only have
a goal and you don't like the process
you'll never hit that goal yeah you have
to enjoy the actual work like if you're
gonna interview people you have to enjoy
interviewing people if you don't you're
never GNA have a good interview Channel
like other guys who love that will crush
you and so if you're just starting out I
think people easily get tricked into
looking at what are the hottest
Industries for this year and what's the
next big opportunity let's go all in on
bitcoin meanwhile you know nothing about
Bitcoin yeah you know and then that's
that's the fastest way to lose your
money so you have to do the thing that
you love rule number three motto success
whoever it is that you look up to like
who's who's done the thing that you want
to do if you love Kanye if you love jobs
or Elon Musk or Oprah or whoever it is
that you look up to look at their story
look at how they got started it'll do
two things for you one it'll it'll give
you the tactics like what did this
person do to become successful and two
it'll give you the motivation because
chances are the people who you look up
to started off with a lot less than what
you currently have right now uh one of
the people I love looking up to is Oprah
she you know was a sexually abuse
growing up she didn't grow up with her
parents uh her grandmother raised her
she was so poor that she her grandmother
bought bags of potatoes and used the
potatoes to then sew it into a dress and
Oprah went to school in potato bags it's
like just imagine showing up in school
in a potato bag as a dress you know it's
it's crazy and so it's hard to imagine
that whatever situation you think is so
terrible in your life right now that
Oprah had it you know way worse than
what you're going through and look at
what she was able to do and so people
have done it so getting out of the
excuses in your head why re what
resources you feel you don't have or
what circumstances life is thrown
against you people with a lot less of
than a lot more and so model their
success and go after it rule number four
learn new skills believing in ourselves
is being true to ourselves we're not
changing who we are to serve others
we're serving others as we are right and
that's critical the authenticity the
genuiness how how did you segue that to
Sala dancing so I never learned to dance
dance growing up I always felt kind of
awkward at a club or whatever dancing
and uh in University I decided okay I'm
gonna I want to learn how to dance and
so there was a there was a ballroom
class that I took with my then
girlfriend not Nina um and we signed up
and took the class and she never really
liked it uh we went couple lessons maybe
a semester and then she didn't want to
do it anymore and it was a kind of class
where you you have to go with a partner
and so I didn't have a partner and I
want to ask another girl to be my
partner when I'm in a Rel it didn't feel
right You' can get in a lot of trouble
doing that Evan Ju Just saying yeah yeah
so it's okay so that's the end of that
whatever fine you know there's other
things to do but then when we end up
breaking up one of the things I said was
well I can go dancing again like why
don't I go learn some dancing and salsa
dancing is the easiest dance to be able
to pick up as a solo person so what I
mean by that is when you're dancing it's
part of the culture to switch Partners
all the time so even if you come as a
married couple it would still be normal
to dance with other guys for you and
other women for me which is part of the
cult now some people stay together but
for the most part the culture is very
interchangeable it's part of the energy
I would imagine yes and borom is very
specific it's like you got your One
partner Sala is more of a street dance
and I just fell in love with it now on
paper I'm too
I take big steps I don't speak Spanish I
didn't learn this growing up uh you know
all of the things that you we could say
are logical reasons why you shouldn't do
it and I think a lot of us live in the
world of well like I can't do that and I
shouldn't do that without ever even
trying and I wasn't even very good at
the beginning either because a lot of
those reasons but I just loved it you
know there's something about like this
is amazing I had to I I signed up for
two different schools to go learn
because I was a slow learner on it but
just to pick it up and and I love
meeting people I love the connection I
love I love I think also learning a new
skill that you thought was too difficult
also is how you build belief in yourself
to say well I couldn't I can't do that
but then you see that you can raises
your belief level to do other things so
that made me a better entrepreneur also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five if evolve your
business how could someone like take
their business and evolve it with them
what kind of things could they
do just think about what is it that you
want to create so for example I had a
successful website it was off my name we
had lots of successful people writing
for it um making money off advertising
coming to the site I was getting
restless and so I said I'm going to try
something new I'm going to I want to go
to YouTube I'm going to try that and I
tried a whole bunch of stuff like you
try things you don't know what the
beginning it was going to work out or
not so I tried YouTube as one of many
things and I liked it and so I kept
doing it and then I kept doing it and I
evolve my business a lot of people don't
even know me from my website they only
know me from my YouTube channel yeah
right because we we've blown up there
but if I get bored of YouTube like the
minute that like I like talking to you
this is great Michael's Michael's doing
an interview I love it let's get on
board the minute this feels like work
like was oh man I got to talk I got to
do interview this sucks I I need to quit
I need to do something else because you
will never win doing work that you hate
okay and so the minute that this feels
like a job I need to stop and go off and
do something else what is it something
else you know like just ask yourself
what what what would I do what do I want
to do what do I want to work on you may
not have the perfect vision yet for like
the final goal but find some small thing
to get started on rule number six find
your message share with is some of your
tips for creating super fans yeah I
think it starts with figuring out what
is your message what do you stand for
what's what's the one word that defines
you it's it's what I talk about my first
book but what why should I follow
you like for me I'm about believe so if
you want a shot in the arm of believe
you want to believe in yourself more
you're going to enjoy everything that I
put out you're going to enjoy this
interview you're going to enjoy my
YouTube videos you're going to enjoy my
my upand cominging IG account you're
going to enjoy all that stuff if you
don't like believe you're not going to
like me you're not you're going to tune
out you've already shut off this podcast
you know you don't you're not going to
like what I have to say and so it's
figuring out what is your message what
is so important and different about you
like why are you doing the thing that
you're doing and then people who like
that message will follow
along most people don't have a message
that they really believe in most people
are just trying to be like somebody else
and that's hard to get like why am I
going to be your Super Fan I'm going to
be that person's Super Fan you're trying
to just be like Logan I'm going to
follow Logan why am I going to follow
you what's so different and so it's
figuring out what that thing is that's
different about you what your message is
that's super clear and so then I think
whenever I need an injection of like if
you're Mr inspiration whenever I need
inspiration or whenever I need energy
like I'm gonna come to you I'm going to
listen to your podcast otherwise what's
the reason if I can't if I can't tell
somebody why they need to listen to your
podcast or buy your book or check out
your channel then you're sunk like you
need people talking about you and the
message that you have um now not every
message is a positive one you know some
people make their name off of tabloids
and making fun of people and that's
that's that's escapism so it's either
like people want to either escape the
life that they hate or they want to go
and build a better life for themselves
so you're either playing on the comedy
or on the Mak in front of somebody else
it's all escaping the life that you
don't have to think about your life you
don't have to think about growth you
just want to shut off your brain and be
entertained or you want to solve the
problems and you want to build a better
life and so that's where you get the
inspiration and the motivation and
practical uh content so just figuring
out where you lie on that path and then
being consistent about it that's why the
journey is important too like if you're
saying hey I love I'm about inspiration
I want to inspire people and everything
I do I want to be an inspiration so I
have my clothing line and I have my
books I have my foundation and now I'm
starting my podcast and if you want to
be inspired listen to my podcast every
week and then even when you're booking
guests right you're booking guests who
are going to inspire people right so
like once you get that identity down
then it makes every decision a lot
easier and you give super fans you give
fans a reason to subscribe and then
become super fans rule number seven
create value the point of the podcast is
to help people be unstuck if it's in
relationships if it's in business if
it's in the idea that they've always had
that they want to do something they want
to achieve it's to un lock that
potential cool so you're in a fortunate
position in that you you're starting it
from scratch but you're not you're not
starting from scratch right you you have
you have some contacts in the industry
you know some people you you can pull
sweaters is a analogy an old Mentor used
to give me okay where like you're
pulling sweaters to get to the head of
the line sure where you know enough
people that you can get to people and
you get to bigger and bigger and bigger
people right so you know there's people
who've used your service you've gone to
events you have connections even you
know after this interview goes up you
can see who follows me an easy hack is
like for current guests see who who
follows them on Instagram and then reach
out to them oh so after this interview
goes live see who follows me on
Instagram and then you can reach out to
them and say hey I had EV KAC call on my
show I'd love to have you on too wow my
name May mean nothing to many people but
it means something to a few people it
allows you to do you know Outreach okay
but so you can you can work your way up
you can get you can get guests on your
show at a faster clip than most people
who are just tur off a podcast cool to
what end like how can I bring you value
how can other people come on and bring
Justin value audience value because
that's I guess the work of the uh that's
the brand like what what are we trying
to create here so unlimited potential
okay awesome I love it I mean I'm all
believe so great I love it is it the
guess is it the format is it people
coming on and coaching you is it like
what are we going to do different on
this podcast compared to all the other
podcasts out there that you know have
the same purpose as you you don't have
to have it all figured out either you
know on this on this call right now but
that becomes the uh the ongoing fact why
would somebody subscribe to the channel
why would they watch what you're doing
you can get guests which is again you
you're not stting from scratch but if
I'm coming on your show how does this
become a different interview or show
than the other ones that that other
people are on that I've gone on other
people's channels and had you know
similar conversations I mean I talk
about believe in potential all the time
so how does it become different is it
about my potential story is it about
your potential story is it about diving
into a specific like and it all comes
from your heart like what do you
actually want to create rule number
eight serve others I don't enjoy being
the center of attention it doesn't it
doesn't um it doesn't do anything for me
but where it started to shift was well I
still want to serve you know like I
still want to feel like what I do
matters to people and that I wake up and
I'm having a meaningful impact and so
whereas I've had to learn to harness the
power of the introvert and and figure
this stuff out as I go but also learn
from other introverts and that okay so I
don't like networking meetings I hate
small talk I don't talk to the guy next
to me on the airplane I all of that
stuff but but I love meaningful
conversations and I can get like I see
Patty an in my calendar like this is
going to be amazing let's go so how how
do how do you show up with that energy
well I don't know I'm not I think
introverts still want to serve
introverts still want to have meaningful
connections introverts still want to
feel like what they do matters and the
more I can tap into that than than my
energy and enthusiasm that is in
everybody um comes out so it's just it
was but that's that was years of I wish
I knew you 10 years ago like things
would have been so much better rule
number nine Tay Rises have you had those
kind of uh
battles in your journey yeah I had one
big one and and after that I didn't have
it again uh and that was when I was 19
when I was trying to make that decision
do I I had all I wanted to do up to that
point was I wanted to be a banker right
that's my dream and I'm my last year
university and I have opportunities to
work at um Merl Lynch and McKenzie was a
strategic consulting company and they
fly me to New York and put me up in the
wall of ptor and like wine and dine and
all this stuff to kind of recruit me to
try to join their company and it was the
job that I always wanted the job the job
man I'm talking 80 to
100,000 first year coming out of
University 19 years old traveling the
world doing mergers and Acquisitions
like what I wanted
meanwhile I've got this
company that's sucking I'm making 300
bucks a month and it was just something
like I don't I don't know what to do
yeah it's confusing uh and my parents
actually were were very supportive and
and said you know what whatever you do
will support you you know they always
told me that I was a cast carmichel my
mom's last name is cast my middle name
is cast I'm a c car Mich I can do
anything that I want it uh but my
friends they were all jealous they're
like what how are you how are you even
thinking about this right how are you
not just saying yes to these job
opportunities uh and I was really torn I
didn't know what I wanted to do I didn't
know which path to go in and then the
thing that helped me and the thing that
I still use today whenever I'm faced
with this kind of decision is I think
about not regretting my
decisions and I fast forward to life at
90 or however old I am when I'm like
dying on my deathbed and thinking back
will I regret having said yes or no to
this decision and I could live with
saying no to the job because I knew I
could get another job right but I
couldn't live with giving up on the
company because I didn't know if it
would come by again and so I gave I said
I'll give myself a year I'll give myself
a year I'm GNA try this company and see
how if I can make it take off and if it
doesn't I'll go back into the job market
and just that idea of not trying to live
with regret is then that it was super
difficult at that point like decision
ever to make in my life but ever since
then I just I just think about it this
thing that I'm thinking about doing now
this impossible decision am I going to
regret not doing it and then that makes
the decision easy then I have to go out
and do it and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some special bonus Clips make
today count make today
count uh I try to go into every day
thinking I want to make something today
that my grandkids are going to be proud
of so like this interview with Michael I
want my grand kids to see it I want to
tell my grandkids a story about this
crazy guy Michael who stayed up till 3
in the morning to interview me and now
he's off with Grant cardan as his
business partner running all of these
multi-billion dollar real estate
Investments like I wanna I wanna I want
to make today count and I think it's so
easy to put something off till tomorrow
or the next week like that's a great
idea that I learned from Michael I'll do
that tomorrow and then it becomes the
next day and we we think we have so much
time and then you look back it's like
where did the past five years go like it
just what happened I wanted to do all
these things and nothing has happened
yet and so again if you approached every
day with the mindset of today I'm gonna
make something that's G to count I'm
gonna make something that I want my
grandkids to see and again if you take
that approach every day you're gonna
make some amazing things of the next
year inflict so much pain on yourself a
future regret that if you don't do this
thing how painful it's going to be for
you how you're going to regret it your
entire life that it forces you
into action to do the thing that will
make yourself proud that will build the
life you want that will help create the
dream that you know you're capable of
doing reminding yourself every day of
how amazing you are I think it's one of
the greatest gifts you can give yourself
and it's not about ego it's about
confidence confidence comes from a place
of strength ego comes from a place of
weakness and insecurity so it's time to
step into your confidence and remind
yourself how amazing you really are this
video is going to help so I used to have
a lot of problems with with ego versus
confidence I used to feel like who am I
why do people need to hear my story uh I
was profiling all these different
successful entrepreneurs and people kept
asking well where are you how come we
can't see what you're about where did
you come from and I always felt like my
story doesn't matter I'm I'm profiling
Diva Goggins and Steve Jobs and and all
these people why do you care about I
mean sure I sold my first business had a
had an exit it but it's nothing compared
to what all these other people have done
and I always shrouded it covered it
under ego like well that's such an
egotistical thing to do but really I was
just playing small I was cheating people
the opportunity to learn to get better
to grow from my story that my story has
value it's the belief that my story had
value that took some time to really work
up even making videos on my channel the
number one most requested person for top
10 was me and I resisted for maybe 2
years of even making an Evan carmichel
top 10 cuz I just felt not good enough I
felt like that's such an ego play and
not coming from a place of confidence
and yes my message has impact has
meaning can help the world and the first
Evan carmichel top 10 came out from my
team so my birthday birthday I think it
was my birthday birthday or Christmas my
team put together with the with the
support of my hardcore fans my first top
10 no not yet EV
you want to watch it I'm a little scared
and that's the one that that went live
on the channel and ever since then we've
done a regular series of me being on the
channel but it's it's been a real
progress for me it's been a a real
Evolution it's taken me a long time and
hopefully you can get there faster this
has been almost 20 years of me sharing
ideas and content and and slowly
stepping into the light and slowly
building more confidence more belief and
I hope that with the content I'm making
and the experiences I'm sharing you can
get there a lot faster lean in on
service that I'm here to serve I'm here
to help I'm trying to do something that
good what's the intention behind this
thing you're about to do if you're going
to go on stage or you're going to make a
video you're going to make a video walk
into the park right what's the intention
is the intention to to hurt somebody to
screw somebody over to lie to them to
cheat no hopefully not not if you're a
fan of this channel come on now the
intention is good the intention is
positive you want to you want to serve
you want to help you want your message
to Hope F impact somebody's life if
you're selling a product or service yes
you you want to make money and you're
trying to solve a problem you're trying
to help people so anytime I make it
about you you know the people watching I
make it personal uh I focus on service
instead of focusing on me how am I
received how are how are you liking me
how is that guy who passed by what is he
thinking about me right when that's
that's about me I'm worried about me I'm
in my own head I'm I'm playing small
anytime I can focus on other people and
the value that they're hopefully going
to get at least with the intention
I wouldn't be uh maybe so bold or or
Brave to say no this is going to be my
best video ever but it's my intention
always it's my intention to try to make
the best video I've ever done and and
give as much value as I can and to serve
and hopefully one person is touched by
this video and it means something to
them right so when you're afraid to do
something focus it on service the
world's biggest problem is a lack of
belief that the biggest problem for me
for you for Brendon bashard for
everybody is a lack of belief you
believe in yourself to the extent of
what you've done that you can do it
again but you don't believe in The Next
Step you don't believe that you can go
from here to here this is why I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something like you
you're a genius you are the best in the
world at something and it's not what
what you went to school for it's not
what your parents taught you it's not
what the people around you are doing
it's probably something very very very
different and unlike your parents or
grandparents it's actually possible now
because of Technology because of the
internet it's actually possible for you
to go off and be this Michael Jordan
level genius at something you don't need
to have the resources you don't need to
have the education you don't need to
have the connection because it's all the
walls have been broken down and it's
only getting
easier but it's still the lack of belief
in the ability to do the thing people
say well I think cancer is the world's
biggest problem great I think cancer
should have been solved by now the woman
who would have solved cancer is a
manager an accounting fir firm doing
work that she hates because one she
never believed in herself enough to uh
go down
the rot to become a doctor or researcher
uh and two even if she started she
didn't believe in herself enough that
she could be the genius at it the the
Michael Jordan level genius best in the
world or something and this is this is
what happens we settle we get stuck we
get complacent we we find all these
reasons and excuses why we can't do it
we really it's just fear and lack of
belief and every time you break through
every every major breakthrough that I've
had in my life has come on the other
side of me believing in myself more that
I could go off and do that thing use the
nose as fuel and I add this in not
because I use it but because I know it
works for a lot of other people and and
I'm channeling Tom billu right now this
is one of the things that Tom does
that's he credits to having his success
if you know Tom impact Theory built a
billion dollar business with with Quest
and now has his Awesome YouTube channel
he has a list he has a list of all the
people who doubted him who didn't
believe in him and whenever he feels
like he really needs that extra
motivation he goes to that dark place
and looks at that list and say all these
people did not believe in me I'm going
to show them wrong I don't do that I
don't get a lot of power and strength
for myself of being in the dark side of
proving somebody wrong but I think it
can be very beneficial for people and a
lot of people do talk about it so I
wanted to at least give that to you as
an option use those NOS as fuel use that
your mom telling you that you suck and
you can't make it maybe she doesn't say
that you suck but that you can't make it
using your friends or haters online
saying that you're never going to do it
using that as fuel to say I'm going to
show you and prove you wrong I just
think the danger is if you live in there
for too long if you're only fuel for the
dark side it consumes you if you're only
doing something to prove somebody wrong
you're never going to stay consistent
persistent enough because it's not a
good enough reason at the core of doing
the thing has to be you love doing the
thing you want to serve right you're
built to serve you want to serve you
want to help you want to help right uh
but if you have to channel the dark side
every now and then use those nose as
fuel to help you get forward then go for
it and give it a shot a key reason why
you are not in an amazing place right
now is because you do not have amazing
people around you think about it how
many of the people that you hang out
with consistently make you feel amazing
force you to grow and push you to be a
better version of yourself you can't do
this alone the people around you need to
change so you can change so I recently
came back from a mastermind group in
Puerto Rico with Brendan bashard and a
bunch of super successful people and one
of the things that I love the most was
how he works with his friends and
there's so many people say don't work
with friends don't work with family but
he's built this group of people who love
working together some have joined his
team some are are business partners in
different Ventures where they're genu
friends and they've been friends for in
some cases over a decade I love that
model I love working with people that I
that I know that I'm connected to I love
working with friends I don't see it as
business is one thing and personal is
something else maybe that's just me I I
would much rather work with somebody who
I get along with than just have a you
know business relationship and that in
particular made me think of my friend
Mark drer and Mark's got a a marketing
company called Phantom media we had a a
podcast together called the self po
podcast if you want to go check it out
and I've known Mark for over a
decade and he sent me a message not too
long ago saying that what I need in a
marketing partner for my business isn't
what he can provide yet that he's still
a little bit away whether it's a year or
two years or whatever it is away from
being able to help me with what I need
both from a experience point of view a
resource point of view a uh you know
team point of view that he wasn't ready
to help me and that he felt like he was
holding me back that if I had somebody
else then I would grow faster and it
never sat right with
me until I went to Brendan's event and
then what came back was realizing I want
to grow with Mark I want to grow with my
friends I don't want to just be at the
top and then have a bunch of business
associates around me and then my friends
are like way down here right I want to I
want to build it together there's value
for me in building it together Beyond
just a business Roi and I think
ultimately long term it actually leads
to a Better Business
Roi and I love that I love that Brendan
does it and it provided a model for what
is possible for me to be able to go off
and create and build and so whether it's
Mark whether it's Alex from Tonto D
salsa whether it's Jeremy from the
YouTube coaching business that that we
started together I like being able to
work with people who I can call friends
and I want to be able to do that
more and so whether you come on board
and you you you bring on your friends or
family uh definitely being around people
who push you who make you feel energized
who build you up who you could see for
the next 20 years being people that you
want to hang with I think is really
really really really really really
important I'm a big believer in altering
your environment I don't think that it
has to be physical to start so let me
break down a couple ideas for you that I
think will help one your physical
surroundings of where you are right now
what's on your wall what you watch the
Youtube videos that you consume
hopefully my channel the books you read
all of that starts the process of
changing what gets into your mindset
more important than the physical
environment is this it's what you're
putting in the here and so you can start
that from your home you can start that
from wherever you are and I gain massive
new belief in myself from the videos
from my own channel from consuming the
content from guys like Dan and grendon
Bard and Tony Robbins and all these
people every day in my head it it pulls
me up it makes me think bigger it makes
me feel like there's something more and
injects myself with the belief and so
you can do that right now immediately
look at your habits look at your routine
look at the people you talk to look at
the the podcast you're listening to and
the videos you're watching and is it
part of a daily practice it needs to be
a daily practice that you're putting
that into here to help you start playing
a bigger game the greatest thing that
you can do for yourself is be proud of
your daily effort it's not about how
many likes or views or praise you get
that stuff doesn't actually matter it'll
hit you and make you feel great for a
second and then it fades the only thing
that matters is when you're all alone
looking at yourself back in the mirror
are you proud of the person that you are
looking at and for too many people
let s and I want to change that in this
video so I recently came back from
Brendan Bard's Mastermind in Puerto Rico
with some super high level people uh
about 25 of us sat around a table
masterminded for 3 days and a lot of the
people I've profiled here on this
channel and I normally hate these kinds
of events that are open that are loose
that require just networking and talking
to people right if there's a structure
or if you need help I love it if it's
and just spend the next hour and a half
mingling and talking to people I hate it
I even the thought of it right now is
making me cringe I hate it so
much but when I got there Brendan
challenged me to say make sure you ask
for help make sure you don't just give
give give give give but that you you
leave here asking for help and so that's
always been a challenge for me
networking events plus asking for help
we're hitting like both things that I'm
historically have sucked at and and they
struggle with and so I decided I'm going
to be proud of my effort today I'm going
to go off and do it I'm I'm not going to
go home I'm not going to go back to my
hotel room right the hotel room was
super close on that 2hour break 90minut
break 3-hour break I could have gone
back to my hotel room and done some work
I had lots of logical reasons why I
should go back and do work everything is
behind because I'm not working but
really it' be an excuse because I'm
afraid because I'm afraid of staying
there because I'm afraid of not being
instru C environment because I'm afraid
of just talking to people because I'm
afraid to ask for help and so I decided
I'm going to play full out I'm going to
play full out I'm going to maximize this
time I've got here I'm I'm taking this
time off of work because I need to
develop the relationships I need to get
the help that I need to get and I'm
going to I'm going to ask for it I'm
going to I'm going to be proud of my
effort even if I fail even if I suck
even if it doesn't work out I'm going to
be proud of my
effort and it wasn't the most uh
amazing result right it was was awkward
I was standing around and trying to join
people's conversations it was super
awkward and cringeworthy but I was proud
that I did it I was proud that I tried I
can look at myself in the mirror and
said I did that I tried my best pat on
the back I'm amazing for other people
who are there too they're naturally
extrovert they don't understand what it
is to be introvert to be shy to join in
on conversations to not ask for help and
how hard that can be uh so for them it
was easy to just start conversations and
introduce themselves for me it was
really difficult but self-worth
self-love self- pride comes from doing
difficult things that you don't think
you're capable of and so I was really
proud of my effort for doing it and if
if you did the same thing it's something
I still try to do every day to be proud
of my effort in making this video I want
to be proud of my effort that I tried my
best to make the best possible video yet
you may not achieve it it may not happen
but if every day you woke up and you try
to do the thing to make yourself proud
right the effort you're going to create
amazing amazing amazing amazing things
where if you stay constrained by just
what you know and what you're capable of
and what you're good at you never grow
you just stay inside your comfort zone
forever and ultimately end up hating
your life you want to swim forever adopt
the mindset that you want to swim
forever most people if you're thinking
about swimming you're swimming to reach
the island right if you're swimming out
the ocean you're swimming to reach the
Island the island is is some gold the
island is I want to hit a million
subscribers I want a million in revenue
or or whatever some arbitrary goal the
goal isn't to hit the
island your intention shouldn't be to
hit the island it should be to swim you
have to love swimming you want to swim
forever I want to swim
forever every now and then you might
need to look
back you know and see how far you've
come see how far you swam every now and
then we need that that mindset that that
that gratitude that perspective to say
wow I'm I'm so much further ahead Than I
Used to Be Right big challenge with
Achievers is we don't feel like we've
done enough especially with high
Achievers you don't feel like you've
done enough and and that can often be a
drive forward but sometimes it's so
overwhelming that it actually puts you
in a negative state where where prevents
growth so in those moments you look back
you see how far you swam like wow I've
come a long way compared to who I used
to be the the lishments the belief
systems the mindset the relationships
like the personal development how much
have you grown if you actually think
about it how much have you grown in the
past 5 years is probably crazy if you're
a fan of this channel you're watching
this video you've grown a lot in the
past 5 years and every now and then when
you're feeling low you need that
perspective shift to look back and see
how far you've come but otherwise it's
forward growth more growth you want to
swim forever you don't want to hit the
island you want to swim forever we've
all experienced those moments where you
you hit a
goal and then and then what what what do
you feel you feel a moment of Happiness
of of accomplishment and then like oh is
that is that all there is you when I hit
a million subscribers on YouTube like
that was the drive that was the goal I
want to hit a million subscribers on
YouTube I wanted to hit it I don't even
remember what the goal I wanted to hit
it before Gary I wanted to hit a million
subscribers before Gary ve and we did
it and they're like oh I'm still the
same person
somehow we feel that when we accomplish
something we're going to feel different
we're going to be different you're going
to be a different person when you hit
that goal and it's it we end up getting
confused because it's not even about the
goal you become a different person in
the pursuit of the
goal I've studied more successful people
than most people just in the nature of
the work that I do and there's a reason
why the number one rule for Success over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over again is you have to love
what you do you have to love the process
successful people they love the process
they love the doing they love the actual
showing up every
day I'm sitting here at a at a Nina's
inside there can we see Nina's inside at
a at a TNT it's a Chinese grocery store
she's inside doing shopping I'm sitting
here in the car making videos why cuz I
I like it I like I like the process I
like it's not about how many subscribers
I have on the channel I like feeling
like this matters that you I'm so
grateful that you're thank you honestly
thank you for watching this video I'm so
grateful that you're here watching this
video that I could make something from
my car that's worthy of somebody else's
attention thank you I love this we've
done over 10,000
videos why cuz I love it like if it's
just a strategy if you're just trying to
reach the island you
drown if you're just trying to reach the
island you drown you have to love
swimming this is the mistake most
entrepreneurs make when they're first
getting started is you're just chasing
an opportunity but you don't actually
love the process this is a
great uh quote one of my favorite quotes
of all time it's an African saying that
beyond the mountain is more
Mountains and it's similar to the
swimming analogy beyond the mountain
there's more Mountains what do you do
when you get to the top of the mountain
there's another mountain to climb you
don't you don't ever want to get to the
top of the mountain think about it if
you if you hit the
top you're going to start to hate your
life because there's no growth because
we want more growth we want more
learning we want more progression if you
felt like you hit the top that's the
fast path down to depression beyond the
mountain is more Mountains it's the
greatest quote of all time at least one
of them I love that one I think a Ted
Turner's father whose goal was to be a
millionaire and then he hit the million
and he killed
himself because he thought you know he
wasn't happy with his life he wasn't
happy with his his process he wasn't
happy with what he was doing every day
but if he hit a million dollars then
everything's going to change then he's
going to be a different person he hit
his million and he was the same person
he wasn't happy so he killed
himself so Ted Turner who's you know a
billionaire one of the wealthiest people
in the world decided I'm going to set a
goal so big that I'm not going to hit
it and that's the point of having a
vision you know a mission like something
so big Beyond yourself that you never
hit it I want to solve the world's
biggest problem
that people don't believe in themselves
enough I'm never going to do that it's
not it's not going to happen not in my
lifetime and yet I wake up every day
trying to make that happen in my
lifetime you have to want to swim
forever you are spending way too much
time on things that you hate doing that
you never want to be great at and it's
hurting your
business I'm here in Puerto Rico I'm
speaking at an event with Brendan
bashard his Mastermind group and one of
the things I've learned from people
who've accomplished a lot have had big
success is that you are great at
something right you're you're the
Michael Jordan of something you have
genius level Talent at
something but you're not spending enough
time doing it you're spending too much
time on the things that you hate that
you don't ever want to be great at that
you can respect and say hey this is
important for my business but it doesn't
mean that you should be the one doing it
so I spoke at this event and I'm talking
to entrepreneurs and and they're thought
leaders and they want to have their
YouTube channel want to build up their
presence and brand name and recognition
and there's so many people who when they
get started they spend 20 minutes
recording a video and then 4 hours
editing it to put the right graphics on
to put the right intro and extra
music now if you are in the graphics
business if you are an editor then your
stuff has to look amazing but if you're
not then you're training the wrong skill
this is the thing you're training
the wrong skill there's things in your
business that you're spending so much
time on that you never want to get great
at you're training the wrong skill you
should not be doing it discount it it
doesn't mean you get rid of it
completely it doesn't mean that you
disrespect it completely but if you're
spending 20 minutes recording a video
and 4 hours editing it you're training
the wrong skill you need to switch it
you need to spend 4 hours recording
it 4 hours recording and 20 minutes
editing it or 0o minutes editing it I
don't care because people who are
watching your videos if you're thought
leader they're coming for this they're
coming for what's in your head they're
not coming for how great your editing
skills are now that doesn't mean you
disrespect the editing it doesn't mean
you never hire an editor it doesn't mean
you learn
zero but the thing that will get you to
be able to afford to hire an editor is
making awesome content that comes from
here because no amount of editing is
going to save save it if your ideas suck
it's the thing that holds so many
entrepreneurs back from making videos if
you don't want to make videos if you
don't want to be on YouTube awesome but
there's something in your own business
that you're taking that same equivalent
to so look at your calendar look at
where you're spending your time look at
how much time is actually being spent on
things that are moving the business
forward that you love that you could be
the greatest in the world potentially at
chances are that number is like
5% and you need to move it that needs to
be
85%
that's when you start creating
magic and it's not going to be perfect
releasing that video won't be perfect
you're going to look at it and say man
that really sucks I would love to have
better lighting I would love to have
better sound I would love to have better
editing I would love to have better gear
great work towards it but that can't be
the reason why you don't post and it
can't be the reason why you're spending
all this time doing work that you hate
you can only do so much by
yourself I love being in army of One
right when when you get an idea you have
to do something about it you will it
into existence and if people don't want
to help you then you will it into
existence being Army of one but there's
a lot of different ways to win and
you're going to win the hardest and
think that you're the best at and so you
start and so you start and so you
start but you can't do everything not
very well so you pick the thing this is
the this is the most important thing
that will help give you Leverage your
business to help you turn from just kind
of making a little bit of money kind of
making a little bit of momentum to
having massive momentum to making way
more
leverage figure out the thing that when
you do is
fantastic and everything else Almost
Doesn't Matter tell the people around
you so Nina Nina stepped out but uh Nina
my son my team my family I'll let them
know hey if I say scary difficult or
hard I want you to let me know if I say
to you in any conversation I can't
because it's scary or it's difficult or
it's hard I need you to call me out on
it because I'm not I still don't catch
all of them it's a lot more than it used
to be and I'm probably I don't know 90
95% of the way there but there'll still
be some small percentage and having
people hold you
accountable is really important Now the
default thinking for them is going to be
what are you talking about you you're
always doing of these things you're
always showing up you're always doing
scary difficult hard in in my case yeah
but not like I could be there's there's
another level to
this and everything I want out of life
my mission my my vision my boldness is
on the other side my great life is on
the other side of even more scary
difficult and
hard I have to start living it and so I
need help and catching it so you use
yourself as as step step one as the
first part but then if you can as a
bonus bring in the accountability to the
other people in your life who can help
you catch it and you're not allowed to
get angry at them you're not allowed to
get frustrated at them if if you say one
of your trigger words and they say you
just said it you're going to want to say
nah but this that doesn't count it
doesn't mean it I was thinking something
stop letting yourself off the
hook instead just say you're right I
need to go do the thing and the more you
can train that trigger word came up I'm
doing the thing trigger word came up I'm
doing the thing it's scary I'm doing it
it's difficult I'm doing it it's hard
I'm doing it just because you start
shifting your identity you start
changing your self talk now you start to
become the person that you're proud of
you start to become the person that you
you say you want to be you start to
actually become the person you become
the best version of you most people grew
up with an unhealthy view of money some
people think that money is everything
that the next person person you see the
next customer you talk to that's your
next suit that's your next car and other
people think that money is the root of
all right or the love of money is the
root of all evil right to make money
you're evil you're slimy you're gross
you're ripping people off most people
grow up in one of those two camps that's
the lesson that's been taught you by
your parents the truth is money is just
a tool money is an amazing tool that
lets you accomplish amazing things and
if you are an entrepreneur and want to
have success making money has to be in
your top five list of priorities if it
is not in your top five then you're not
making money but it can't be number one
money can't be your number one priority
there has to be something that is more
important than it and that's your
purpose I don't really usually talk a
lot about money on my videos um maybe I
should maybe I should talk more about it
I think it's important I think there's
just so much out there that seems to be
money money money money that I'm trying
to go against it to say like purpose is
number one you have you're built to
serve if you're just chasing money
you're never going to win wi I think I
see too many entrepreneurs just chasing
money and so a lot of the content that I
make is more purpose-- driven but
there's still there's still I think a
lot of people who are purpose-- driven
who've started a business for the right
reasons and they don't know how to make
money and so maybe I need to switch up
some of the content that I make as well
to help change the perspective around
money my personal view is I hate
spending money till I'm making money I
love making money it's not number one
right serving believ in entrepreneurs is
number one but again it's in the top
five because if I didn't make money I
wouldn't have a team I wouldn't have
people to help me make this video it'd
be me by myself trying to put together
one piece of content you know a week or
maybe a day just you know filming by
myself but instead I have this team
people who I'm super appreciative of and
I can afford that because I'm making
money doing the business that I'm doing
you are where you are in life and
business because of your standards it's
just not important enough for you yet to
hit that next level for you for me for
all of us we've settled we've settled
for what currently is and haven't
demanded from ourselves that we reach
that next level change your standards
change your life so I was recently
talking to Alex on my team and he helps
me run tronto dance salsa the largest
dance school for salsa in North America
probably and he recently went through
this weight loss challenge and and he
lost I don't know I want to say 30 lbs
and now he's sticking to this really
thin l of between 150 and 155 lbs that's
his goal that's his standard when he's
when he's getting close to 155 he slows
down on the eating and when he's around
150 he has a little bit more and he's
constantly staying in this band because
he set a new standard for himself even
though he might have been 180 or 185
before now anywhere close to 155 is
going to be too much like that's it
that's my new standard that's the lowest
I'm going to go which is crazy high
compared to what he was before he's now
trying to bring that same standard to
his business so what he's trying to do
every day now is if you follow him on
Instagram is he's posting at the end of
the day how proud he is of the effort he
put in how proud is he of the effort
that he put in at of 10 and sometimes
you see it's 5.5 sometimes you see it's
a seven and every now and then it's an
eight or even a nine how proud he is of
the effort that he put in this is now
the area where he needs to raise his
standards and I was talking to him
yesterday and a big breakthrough that
happened was said Alex you lost 30 lbs
man or or more from your weight loss
Journey now the idea of being over 155
is crazy when you used to be 180 right
or 185 it's crazy you need to take that
same approach to your business to your
effort that you're proud of yourself
every day for what you're doing anything
under eight should be considered a cheat
day anything under eight is like you had
a cheat day on your diet every now and
then on his weight loss Journey he had a
cheap day he had a moment of weakness he
he went for a giant pizza and a cake
because he was starving and he couldn't
control himself but it was these one-off
moments right it was like once every 3
weeks or something and and continue down
that now needs to be your daily effort
if it's under eight that's like your
eating cake and pizza eight needs to be
the new waterline that if you're getting
close to it it's like holy cow I can't I
need to work hard I need to I need to
accomplish I need to go off and do just
like 155 now is that Benchmark for
himself and putting into those terms
made sense for him because he had higher
standards now for himself in what he ate
in how he took care of his body than he
did for what he was doing into his
business and so it's the same thing for
you you want to grow you want to get
better you want to improve you have to
raise your standards you have to now not
settle for where you're at because where
you're at is good this is the problem
good is the enemy of great right where
you're at is good it's good it's not
amazing but it doesn't suck cuz if it
sucked if you hated it every day you
would have to find a way out but because
it's good you don't do it you don't
change it's not important enough for you
to want to get to that next step there
is no longer any acceptable reason why
you can't get the mentors that you're
after and start winning the
opportunities that are in front of you
right now did not exist for your parents
and it's only getting easier but you
still have to do your part you still
have to reach out you still have to want
it it's actually less about winning the
lottery and where you came from and much
more about how badly do you want it and
how much you going to put in to get
after it because if you are willing to
put in the work you can beat out
somebody with a thousand times more
resources than you so every night I go
on Twitch and I stream My League of
Legends Games twitch.tv/ Team here and
there was a guy who joined me last night
from the Philippines so he's from the
Philippines and he says that his goal is
to be a professional League of Legends
player and the challenge is there not a
big League of Legends scene in the
Philippines there's no professional
teams there's only one player right now
named dick Smithy who's a jungler where
did he go he was jungler for Team Liquid
he signed with a new team it escapes me
right now there's one person who was
born in the Philippines who's who's a
pro player right now and makes his
living as a professional League of
Legends player this guy joins my live
stream last night and he says he's a
support player from the Philippines and
that's his ambition he's going to grind
it out he wants to get notice he wants
to get picked up he wants to be a
professional League of Legends
player the crazy thing is that's
actually
possible it's actually possible for him
to do it it's actually possible for him
to get training for him to get
mentorship for him to reach out to for
him to get in contact with people here
he is he's in the Philippines I'm in
Canada and we're talking we're
connecting on my live stream it's
actually possible it wasn't possible
even 10 years ago definitely not for his
parents you look at what his parents are
doing where they came from you could
have some dream but at that time the
dream was probably just to come to North
America or just to have this one little
thing that that existed in the world
currently right this limited mindset
because there were limited opportunities
but right now the opportunities are
insane you have a thing called the
internet people didn't have it before
the opportunities are insane you are
competing against the world which is bad
for a lot of North Americans but it's
amazing for everybody who's outside or
amazing for anybody who is willing to
work hard it's not even bad for North
Americans it's bad for anybody who's
lazy who's slow who's maybe had things
handed to them there's a lot of people
in North America who had nothing handed
to them but they're willing to work hard
if you are willing to work hard if you
are willing to show yourself it's never
been easier to win Justin Bieber got
discovered on YouTube you don't need to
have a manager anymore you don't have to
go through the system you don't want to
I got a publisher for my deal but you
don't want to have a publisher you don't
Publishers reject you great go off and
sell publish David goggin did lots of
people created number one best sellers
just from self-publishing you can bet on
yourself if you're willing to work hard
if you're willing to put in the effort
it's never been easier to win and so I
look at this guy from the Philippines it
might be easier for me right me sitting
here in Canada uh if my goal was to be a
professional League of Legends player
sure it might be easier for me sure I
might have more resources sure I could
afford coaching and and go to
tournaments and meet
people but it's also never been easier
for him because in the past it would
have been only available to me now it's
available to anybody and if he has the
heart and the hustle and the drive and
the intention and the will to go off and
do it every day he can Crush someone
like me even if I have a thousand times
more resources than him and you can too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on on this
video I will showcase you and celebrate
you somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch Mr Beast top 10 rules for
Success watch the video next to me I
think you're going to enjoy continue to
believe I will see you there a lot of
people get analysis paralysis and
they'll just sit there and they'll plan
their first video for 3 months and your
first video is not going to give views
period it's not your first 10 are not
going to give views I can very
confidently say that so stop sitting
there